[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
sur France 3 la scène des élections 2021
les élections départementales ce sera
les 20 et 27 juin prochain ce soir nous
vous proposons deux débats pour vous
aider à faire votre choix dans un peu
plus de 50 minutes on va s'intéresser à
la Nièvre mais au début de cette soirée
par l'Yonne et pour en débattre nous
avons avec nous Isabelle le froment me
Meurice des républicains bonsoir bonsoir
également présent Xavier courtois
candidat divers droites bonsoir bonsoir
Jean-Christophe letière du rassemblement
national bonsoir et Frédéric Colas du
Parti socialiste bonsoir bonsoir
on va débuter cette émission avec le
contexte politique et je vous propose
tout de suite de regarder bien la
composition de l'assemblée sortante on
va le voir une large majorité pour le
groupe d'union
lrudi Isabelle froment Meurice vous êtes
la représentante sur ce plateau de
l'amazorité sortante d'ailleurs c'est
vous qui êtes là ce soir et ce n'est pas
Patrick gendro qui pourtant nous a
annoncé dans un premier temps qui serait
présent qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
un problème d'agenda je crois j'en sais
pas plus moi j'ai été averti
je crois qu'on s'est vu samedi je crois
que donc samedi que je prenais le mon
tour pour représenter la majorité du
département et j'en suis évidemment très
honoré
sa candidature à sa réélection pour la
présidence
il y a pas d'ambiguïté ce soir vous
pouvez me dire il est bien le chef de
fil de la liste unis pour l'Yonne
mais oui absolument je vous demande ça
parce que ces dernières années dans
votre département dans l'Yonne
la famille on peut dire qu'elle a quand
même traversé quelques quelques zones de
turbulences ce soir vous ne dites quoi
que tout le monde est réuni je dis que
c'est tout à fait normal qu'il y ait des
sensibilités différentes vous avez
souligné la majorité pléthorique
de sensibilité droite centre
j'allais dire donc c'est normal que il
est toujours après ça revient des
querelles de personnes si nous avions
une majorité beaucoup plus étroite
évidemment ça serait plus facile de
faire front face à l'adversaire là c'est
toujours beaucoup plus
j'allais dire délicat
tout le monde représente des
sensibilités peu
[Musique]
ouproubles
majorité qui est guise les appétitifs
oui je pense que c'est toujours été
comme ça
je me retourne vers vous maintenant
vous étiez en 2015 candidat de cette
alliance lrudi ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
écoutez effectivement vous aviez raison
de le mentionner cette droite dans le
département de l'Yonne avait plusieurs
acteurs majeurs et une jeune génération
qui était composée notamment de
Guillaume l'arrivée on va commencer par
le citer lui qui reste le président de
LR je crois dans le département de
l'Yonne et puis il y avait également un
autre personnage politique et non des
moindres Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
secrétaire d'État qui aide vous-même un
proche on peut dire de Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine je vais vous dire ami plus que
proche politiquement je crois que c'est
vraiment une question d'amitié et je
crois que d'ailleurs les relations
politiques doivent aussi se forger au
travers des relations humaines et
c'est un peu le grand absent de ce
scrutin Jean-Baptiste Lemoine comment on
peut interpréter le fait qu'il ne soit
pas présent voilà il y a deux
personnages qui finalement ont choisi de
quitter cette assemblée Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine on vient de le citer et Nicolas
Soret aussi très largement les débats de
notre assemblée mais Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine il s'était présenté façon de
révilliers pour la présidence il y a 6
ans pourquoi il est pas retourné cette
année je crois que en fait les tensions
sont restées importantes au sein de
cette majorité même si elle
n'apparaissait pas nécessairement au
grand jour toujours mais elle le sont
elles le sont restées et je partage pas
tout à fait la vie de de ma collègue
concernée Isabelle qui qui nous dit que
effectivement Patrick Jandro sera le
chef de fil il est j'attends de voir le
soir du deuxième tour et voir quelles
seront les candidats dans ce département
qui est toujours un mystère sur le plan
des alliances politiques pour vous c'est
pas si simple ah non ça n'est pas du
tout
en 2015 votre partie de leur
rassemblement national est arrivé en
tête dans neuf des 21 cantons de l'Yonne
avec plus de 30% des voix vous pensez
faire aussi bien ce scrutin
beaucoup mieux même on est même à peu
près convaincu à la rencontre de nos
électeurs à la rencontre de nos
concitoyens on se rend bien compte qu'il
y a une vraie dynamique derrière le
rassemblement national puisque en
réalité nous sommes le seul parti en
présence qui revendique c'est
c'est pas terminé de beaucoup mieux
c'est quoi votre objectif ecoutez on
verra vous savez très bien que et vous
êtes beaucoup mieux informés que moi
pour savoir que on peut pas pronostiquer
quoi que ce soit mais en réalité on fera
certainement beaucoup mieux puisque en
face de nous nous avons en effet une
droite décousue qui est alliée à la
République en marche comme vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure si on remonte il
y a 6 ans au petit flashback en 2015
vous aviez remporté un canton celui de
villeneuve-sur-lyonne résultat
l'un des deux élus n'a jamais siéger et
la deuxième a bien siéger mais la
démissionné du rassemblement national
elle a pris une autre étiquette vous
vous présentez pour siéger à l'Assemblée
pour c'est quoi c'est une candidature de
témoignage crée une dynamique pour
Marine Le Pen pardon vous vous cherchez
quoi en fait à créer une dynamique pour
la présidentielle ou a vraiment siéger
puisque il y a des sujets vous avez
obtenu deux sièges comme vous l'aurez
remarqué on a eu quand même quelques
élus dans les dans les municipalités
nous sions systématiquement on essaie de
de participer nous participons dans les
mairies du mois qui est majorité qui
voulait bien nous laisser faire et puis
naturellement nous allons amener aussi
cette cette volonté
au sein du conseil départemental et puis
également ensuite au sein de la région
pour les candidats à la région mais vous
pouvez garantir aux électeurs qui
voteront pour vos candidats que si le
candidat est élu il va siéger dans
l'assemblée
je le garantis et je m'engage pour les
21 binômes en fait de garantir donc en
effet à nos à nos concitoyens à nos
électeurs que le rassemblement national
pardon sera présent sera présent et
travaillera travaillera puisqu'il y a
beaucoup de travail on a plus de
découvrir dans les différentes communes
dans lesquelles nous avons été élu où il
y a 30 ans d'ancienneté des différentes
affinités historiques et on découvre en
effet tout un tas de choses il y a du
travail il y a beaucoup de travail
Frédéric Colas me tourne maintenant vers
vous je l'ai dit vous êtes socialiste
mais vous en faites la représentante de
la gauche puisque pour ce scrutin Lagos
est unie oui exactement pour ce scrutin
et c'est assez historique pour notre
département l'ensemble de la gauche
sais-tu lire donc l'ensemble des
partenaires
PSPC Europe Écologie Les Verts grs LFI
mais aussi des représentants de la
société civile pour présenter des
candidats sur l'ensemble du canton avec
un programme commun autour d'une
bannière appelée l'Yonne en commun
alors justement avec ce contexte on voit
que la droite est divisée dans quasiment
la moitié des cantons on s'attend à une
participation qui sera pas forcément
très élevée donc à une difficulté de se
qualifier pour le second tour est-ce que
ça vous fait un peu rêver sur cette
terre de lionne qui franchement ne vous
ai pas historiquement favorable alors en
effet elle ne nous est pas
historiquement favorable pour autant les
représentants que nous avions dans
l'assemblée départementale n'ont pas
démérités et ont porté leur voix on fait
avancer des projets et le département et
c'est dans cette dynamique là que
l'ensemble des candidats de l'Yonne en
commun effectivement imagine un
changement de cette majorité
départementale votre espoir en termes de
nombre de conseillers notre histoire
c'est le plus évidemment pour avoir une
forte représentation
merci pour ce petit tour en tout cas ce
contexte politique on va maintenant
passer au premier thème de cette
émission et se poser la question de
savoir si le mandat qui arrive ne sera
pas en fait le mandat du retour de
l'investissement et je vous propose tout
d'abord et bien de regarder ces chiffres
ce sont ceux du budget que vous avez
voté en mars dernier on le voit un
budget de 455 millions d'euros donc 92
seront consacrés à l'investissement ça
représente 20% du total l'année dernière
c'était 15% ce qui correspond à peu près
à la moyenne nationale mais c'est un
véritable changement on peut le dire
dans dans ce mandat là puisque les
premières années ont été quand même
marqués par un investissement
relativement faible une certaine rigueur
ça avait été d'ailleurs souligné par la
chambre régionale des comptes qui
estimaient que l'Yonne était un
département en France qui consacrait la
part la plus la moins importante en tout
cas de son budget à l'investissement
Isabelle froment
est-ce que vous vous l'assumez ce bilan
on l'assume parfaitement moi je fais
partie des nouveaux entrants de la
génération 2015
j'ai été assez
j'allais dire
décourager au début puisque
effectivement les finances de la
collectivité se portaient mal que nous
avions un endettement qui était trop
important une marge de manœuvre pour
pour des investissements trop faibles et
donc les premières années de mandat et
là je me retourne vers mon collègue
Xavier courtois nous étions tous en
train de nous plaindre d'assumer en fait
un certain passé
différents où il est des programmes
avaient été engagés à une époque où la
collectivité se portait extrêmement bien
et ces programmes d'arriver toujours pas
échéance c'est-à-dire qu'en fait ils
étaient engagés depuis un certain temps
il se continue et ils sont maintenant la
boîte se terminer c'était l'aide aux
communes ça a été certainement très
important pour le développement d'un
certain nombre de choses dans nos
petites communes mais ça ne permettait
pas d'engager des sommes suffisantes sur
des grands projets servant la totalité
du département et notamment je pense est
bien évidemment à la fibre donc nous
étions assez je vais dire assez
contraint j'allais dire compris aussi
par cette cette
étau financier qui en serrait la
collectivité alors il y a eu beaucoup
d'efforts de fait beaucoup d'efforts de
faits qui ont permis de restituer
justement cette capacité
d'investissement et j'attends avec hâte
le prochain mandat j'allais dire pour
pouvoir enfin lancer les projets que
nous n'avons pas pu lancer sous la
dernière mandature nous en avons lancé
un envergure nous avons recommencé à
investir ces deux dernières années un
peu l'année dernière cette
dans quelques instants ce que vous vous
envisagez si toutefois vous vous
conservez la majorité au sein de ce
conseil Frédéric Colas vos collègues de
la gauche ils ont souvent fustigé un
manque de vision un manque d'ambition de
la part de la majorité
sur ce mandat écoulé vous alors sous
d'investissement oui ou non oui sous
investissement alors avec en effet une
difficulté budgétaire qui était pointée
par le rapport de la Chambre régionale
des comptes mais un sous-investissement
avec deux hausses de fiscalité on le
rappelle en 2015 et en 2016 au début du
mandat un mandat qui se termine avec un
excellent 54 millions donc des capacités
financières qui pouvaient redémarrer et
être enclenché à la à la mi-mandat donc
effectivement ce que nous avons pu
pointer c'est un manque de vision un
manque d'ambition pour ce département de
l'Yonne qui a une position extrêmement
stratégique aux portes de la région
parisienne au sein de la grande région
et qui a raté sur les sujets
d'investissement le travail avec
l'ensemble des collectivités
collègues pointées le sujet des petites
communes le département c'est des
saisies du travail avec les grandes
villes de ce département donc oui
effectivement un manque de vision
stratégique pour l'avenir de l'Yonne et
vous nous dites que cette rigueur
budgétaire le département aurait pu
l'éviter c'est ça elle aurait pu la
travailler en tout cas différemment on
voit que le département a peiné sur
beaucoup de dossiers les sujets de la
fibre par exemple qui ont pris
énormément de retard les dossiers ont
été déposés trois fois pour pouvoir
enfin être éligible et avancer donc je
pense qu'il y aurait pu y avoir des
méthodes différentes
votre votre avis votre avis à vous sur
ce mandat écoulé on a sous investi ou
non il fallait cette rigueur mais
écoutez on voit qu'on a un département
qui est qui est des oeuvres et on voit
que il y a eu beaucoup d'actes
politiques mais on n'a pas eu
spécialement quand même de résultats et
si nos concitoyens qui sont une fois de
plus pénalisés on perd des habitants
4500 de moins aux dernières sentiments
donc on perd des emplois bien sûr on est
un des plus mauvais en termes
d'espérance de vie puisque naturellement
des arts médicales
est une est une réalité on est
couverture médiatique lamentable et même
éventuellement sur du réseau hertzien
puisque tous les secteurs ne pas couvert
et c'est en 2021 c'est très important
puisque c'est vrai que vous l'évoquiez
on est en bordure de région parisienne
beaucoup de gens viennent s'installer
arrivent et ils ne peuvent pas en effet
pouvoir ils ne peuvent pas travailler
ils ne peuvent pas avoir de débit donc
ça limite beaucoup les choses et puis
donc en effet cette ruralité puisque
nous sommes quand même un département
relativement rural cette réalité est en
train de mourir et puis on manque aussi
de service public donc toute ces
caractéristiques toutes ce bilan est
assez catastrophique et en effet on
aurait pu peut-être mettre en place des
choses mais on arrive aux élections et
en fait finalement on retrouve des idées
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui aurait dû
être fait qui n'a pas été fait mais
écoutez
on aurait pu peut-être par exemple avoir
un peu de bon sens on aurait pu
peut-être s'occuper en effet de regarder
pour le manque de médecin c'est
extrêmement important on découvre
aujourd'hui qu'on peut embaucher des
médecins mais c'est pas nouveau ça fait
quand même quatre ans que certains
médecin en exercice disent embaucher
embaucher c'est ce que veulent les
jeunes ça pas été faire on n'a pas
écouté on a lancé des plans pour le
numérique et qu'on a lancé des plans
pour découvrir le résultat n'est pas le
compte n'y est pas ce sont des détails
de la vie du quotidien et puis je vous
épargne l'état des routes qui
catastrophique ou aujourd'hui on a mis
des pansements on se dépêche avant les
élections on a eu l'occasion il y a très
peu de temps de faire une vidéo
là-dessus c'est lamentable voilà c'est
lamentable et c'est même dangereux donc
je vous dis
pardon vous nous direz tout à l'heure ce
que vous proposez pour le prochain
mandat Xavier courtoise l'a dit vous
signez dans un groupe on va dire divers
droites indépendants au sein de cette
Assemblée sortante alors quel bilan vous
faites vous
alors j'ai entendu un certain nombre de
choses je suis d'accord avec le fait que
quand nous sommes arrivés en 2015 la
situation financière de ce département
était était critique vous avez mentionné
le rapport de la Chambre régionale des
comptes il y avait effectivement
beaucoup de choses à faire un certain
nombre de choses ont été engagées
finalement souvent dans la facilité
c'est ceci le reproche que j'ai pu faire
à mes collègues de la majorité c'est
aussi une des raisons qui m'a amené à
sortir de cette majorité tout à l'heure
a été évoquée un choix qui a été fait
lors de l'augmentation de la fiscalité
je rappelle que le département a la
possibilité d'augmenter l'impôt foncier
donc je fais partie de ces élus qui
malgré notre présente présence au sein
de la majorité n'a pas choisi de valider
cette augmentation de la fiscalité
considérant qu'il y avait d'autres
possibilités à faire à commencer par des
économies nécessaires sur s'entendre ça
sur un certain nombre de postes pardon
donc c'est un exemple et puis il y a eu
effectivement
une passation de pouvoir qui qui
finalement pouvait s'attendre je pense
notamment la station de pouvoir de
président au moment où André Villiers
laisse la place à Patrick gendro on
pouvait s'attendre à une accélération
des réformes sur la deuxième partie du
mandat et finalement le compte n'y était
pas et il y a eu une forme de continuité
qui m'a convaincu à quitter cette
majorité estimant qu'il fallait
continuer à aller plus vite plus plus
loin et plus loin dans les réformes
nécessaires afin de retrouver des marges
de manoeuvre donc ça passait par des
économies ça passait vraiment par des
événements la période de rigueur aurait
pu être plus courte et qu'on aurait pu
relancer l'investissement plutôt et
l'augmentation de la fiscalité
finalement il est relativement
juste je termine par rapport à
l'augmentation de la fiscalité c'est une
forme de paresse de la part des élus il
y avait un certain nombre de travaux qui
devait être engagés et des réformes
nécessaires et des économies nécessaires
sur un certain nombre de postes qui
auraient pu nous retrouver nous
permettre de retrouver de la marge de
manoeuvre et et pas aller taper la poche
de du contribuable Isabelle froment
votre majorité elle était paresseuse
je crois pas qu'elle était paresseux je
crois qu'elle a fait un énorme effort
sur le la réduction des coûts de
fonctionnement interne de la
collectivité peut-être que elle aurait
pu accélérer un certain nombre de choses
on était parti sur un plan fibre qui
était assez désastreux à mon à mon goût
puisque on était censé équiper la fibre
en 2030 je me souviens avoir voté ce
plan en me disant en 2030 on aura une
autre technologie qu'on connaît pas
aujourd'hui vu la rapidité d'évolution
bon finalement on a mis le paquet on a
fait cette délégation de service public
et on devrait avoir le département
couvert en 2023
c'est on avait pris beaucoup de retard
c'est un premier
achèvement j'allais dire de quelque
chose on a aujourd'hui un plan beaucoup
plus ambitieux pour la rénovation
énergétique des collèges on a des plans
ambitieux pour un certain nombre de
grands travaux d'infrastructures que des
iconais connaissent en général
mais il y a beaucoup de choses à faire
je j'entendais
monsieur le tierce parler de de la
médecine je pense que là-dessus nous
avons des gros gros efforts à fournir et
vraiment se lancer sur les pistes
justement au début le président en tout
cas n'était pas vraiment favorable même
défavorable à la question des médecins
salariés maintenant vous proposez comme
proposer une expérimentation c'est ça on
se lance oui vraiment là on a commencé
on va le faire on a commencé on a fait
le centre de l'Auxerrois qui est un
centre dans lesquels on a salarié des
médecins
on a vu que ça marchait et pour moi il y
a le salariat des médecins et puis il y
a la médecine de proximité et ça ça fait
partie des pistes que je souhaite qu'on
développe on a un bus des services
publics aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce
qu'on aurait pas un
instant
vous c'est dans votre programme vous
c'est pas vous vous ne parlez pas
d'expérimentation vous êtes convaincus
c'est la bonne solution
d'entendre que la majorité des
départementales reprend des idées de
gauche sur le salariat des médecins donc
oui il faut il faut l'intensifier il
faut intensifier le salarié des médecins
il faut intensifier les bourses aux
étudiants aujourd'hui
il faut pour faire venir des
généralistes mais aussi des spécialistes
ça a été pointé l'Yonne est un désert
médical aujourd'hui avec le contexte
actuel les gens ont des grandes
difficultés de mobilité pour se déplacer
c'est complètement dans les compétences
du département de travailler de manière
transversale sur les sujets de mobilité
et sur les sujets effectivement de
salariés et médecins dans des centres de
santé c'est ce que nous porterons pour
le département pendant mes la mobilité
c'était la région excusez moi je fais
une petite pique comme ça oui
effectivement mais on a on a
certainement envie de continuer dans
cette voie là mais on y consacre déjà un
budget très important au début on était
d'ailleurs assez effrayés parce que on
ne ferait des bourses et bien on
percevait que on allant d'un département
à l'autre il y avait d'autres
départements qui étaient plus riches que
le nôtre qui offrait des bourses deux
fois supérieures et donc ce qui est
absolument inadmissible dans ce système
c'est que en fait il y a une course à
l'échalote entre les différentes
collectivités parce que nous ne sommes
pas les seuls collectivités dans
lesquelles il y a un désert médical et
donc nous y consacrons un budget qui est
quand même assez important et on
s'aperçoit qu'on se fait piquer les les
étudiants en médecine les internes de
médecine qu'on aide ceux qui veulent
s'installer par d'autres départements ou
d'autres régions qui ont des moyens plus
importants ils consacrer
de salariés des médecins mais de qu'ils
viennent avec leurs familles et un
moment donné il faut que le département
reste attractif il faut qu’il en effet
qui ait de la mobilité il faut qu'il y a
du réseau il faut qu'il y ait des
infrastructures il faut qu'il y ait des
gendarmerie il faut qu'il y ait une
école il faut que ce soit vivable
puisque ce n'est pas Auxerre en fait
qu'on va manquer de médecins enfin le
principalement mais c'est dans les zones
rurales dans nos dans nos villages de
1700 habitants on voit qu'il y a des
endroits où ça a fonctionné et on a des
villages qui n'ont plus du tout de
médecins et qui sont pas renouvelés
c'est extrêmement important aujourd'hui
pour nos concitoyens justement c'est un
peu une des problèmes particularité en
tout cas de ce département de l'Yonne
avec un or qui gagne des habitants un
Sud qui en perd comment on fait pour
maintenir un équilibre territorial
monsieur courtois alors si vous me
permettez juste pour revenir sur les
médecins
et en fait c'est pas une idée ni droite
ni de gauche je pourrais citer le
département de la Saône-et-Loire qui a
choisi de salariés des médecins et je
crois que c'était partement est pour
l'instant à droite simplement il s'agit
plutôt d'une question de génération au
fond vous avez désormais
un certain nombre de professionnels de
santé qui sont d'ailleurs souvent des
jeunes femmes et qui préfèrent le
salariat voilà c'est c'est une question
de génération par rapport à
effectivement
et donc s'il y a une vraie paresse de la
part une fois de plus de notre majorité
sur le sujet qui pour lequel il aurait
dû s'en emparer bien plus tôt et pas
attendre la fin du mandat pour le faire
donc pour pour en venir sur la question
que vous me posiez sur le Nord et le Sud
de toute façon
il y a une situation géographique qui
est qui est une réalité donc
pour investir pour répondre en fait la
demande que vous engendrer cette
population qui augmente au nord sont
finalement comment habiller le Nord sans
déshabiller le sud
alors de toute façon le Nord va se
peupler de plus en plus et notamment au
travers des politiques
prioritaires de la ville un certain
nombre de régions de ville de l'argent
parisienne sont en train de réhabiter
leur habitat et vous voyez que au fur et
à mesure de cette habitation vous avez
des populations qui vont s'éloigner des
quartiers qui ont été refaits pour des
raisons de montant de loyer clairement
c'est ce qui se passe déjà dans le nord
du département on le voit
des populations neurolienne etc donc
vous voyez que mécaniquement les choses
se perdent de cette façon là non je
crois que vous avez un département qui
est constitué effectivement d'un or très
dynamique sur le plan démographique et
d'un Sud qu'il faut remettre revitaliser
et là peut-être nous pourrions arriver
aux propositions comment le revitaliser
alors justement je crois que déjà il
faut que ce département comme nous le
mentionnions au travers des propos que
nous avons eu précédemment avec des
propos que je tiens c'est qu'il faut que
le politique se réapproprie les sujets
on peut pas sans arrêt en train de dire
alors c'était souvent le cas dans ce
département on disait la loi neutre nous
a dépossédé d'un certain nombre de nos
missions or finalement vous regardez un
certain nombre d'autres départements loi
notre ou pas loin notre on choisit de
prendre à bras le corps un certain
nombre de sujets afin de permettre
de s'accaparer les sujets qui
préoccupent les habitants et qui
préoccupent les territoires évidemment
les élus de territoire que sont les
maires au président un des sujets qui
permettraient mais là pour le coup je
salue le président gendro qui a choisi
de réunir les présidents
d'intercommunalité afin de travailler à
l'attractivité du territoire alors pour
l'instant nous en sommes qu'à un stade
de réflexion mais je crois que c'est
dans ce sens qu'il faut aller il faut
unir ensemble des forces vives de ce
territoire et l'ensemble des
collectivités communes intercommunalité
et départements mais le département doit
être chef de fil de ses politiques en
matière d'attractivité on pourra
décliner après peut-être ce qu'on entend
pas votre avis sur cette notion un peu
d'équilibre territorial finalement
comment amener plus d'équipe dans le
Nord sans enlever dans le sud
alors
on a une démographie qui grimpe dans le
Nord avec l'attractivité de la région
parisienne la proximité et cette période
que nous avons vécu avec la crise
sanitaire a aussi amené de nouvelles
populations et c'est là l'enjeu du
département il faut fidéliser les
nouvelles populations qui sont arrivées
dans notre département on a été classé
dans le Top 5 des départements qui ont
accueilli des nouveaux habitants
aujourd'hui il faut les fidéliser
comment et ben en misant sur
l'attractivité de notre territoire en
misant sur la mise en valeur de notre
patrimoine on a un département
extrêmement riche extrêmement beau
extrêmement paysager on doit miser sur
ça mais c'est aussi grâce à des
équipements donc des collèges arrêter la
fermeture des collèges c'est
il y a eu un projet de nouveaux collèges
dans ces lyonnais qui finalement
était
ce projet on relancera en tout cas
l'étude
un projet de nouveaux collèges les
prévisions démographiques à 2030 à 2050
elle montre que le nord de l'Yonne va
vraiment grandir en population donc
c'est des projets qu'il faut travailler
avec l'ensemble des collectivités qui
sont autour de nous il faut relancer des
équipements de proximité on parlait des
médecins je pense que les sujets de
mobilité je reprends je reprends ce qui
a été dit la mobilité des seniors la
conférence des financeurs le département
accompagne les sujets de mobilité du
Seigneur et l'accompagne financièrement
à partir du moment où on aura de la
mobilité un désert médical qui se résout
de l'attractivité un monde associatif
accompagné et soutenu et des équipements
rénovés on pourra fédérer l'ensemble des
forces et faire venir effectivement et
surtout fidéliser les nouveaux habitants
de notre département
Isabelle froment Meurice vous nous
disiez que vous aviez hâte d'être à ce
nouveau mandat c'est toutefois vous
gardez la majorité bien sûr pour pouvoir
enfin lancer les investissements ce
serait lesquels vos investissements
prioritaires alors d'abord on a des
compétences dites obligatoires et que
mon voulait dit on a commencé un début
de mandat l'année
la dernière fois qui nous a pas permis
de beaucoup entretenir nos propres
bâtiments collège route etc donc on a un
gros coup de pouce à remettre dessus
je suis une fervente
il soutient des des partenariats
énergétiques dans nos collèges on a
beaucoup de dépenses qui sont
qui mangent le budget des collèges je
trouverai que on va rentrer quand même
on est en 2021 il est temps qu'on s'y
mette donc on a tout un tas de dépenses
à faire de ce côté des collèges on a
évidemment monsieur soulignait le manque
d'entretien des routes c'est vrai que le
budget avait été largement divisé par
deux donc on va le remettre à un état
normal et essayer de rattraper le retard
on a des grands
infrastructures à
construire on est en train d'en
construire certaines mais d'autres sont
encore envisagées je pense au
contournement sud d'Auxerre qui est pas
du tout encore commencé mais qu'on
devrait commencer
je pense on a un bâtiment entièrement à
faire en collaboration avec la ville
d'Auxerre sur les archives
départementales qui va être qui doit
sortir de terre dans le prochain mandat
on a le foyer départemental de l'enfance
qui doit à nouveau sortir dans le
prochain mandat parce qu'il est très
dégradé donc on a beaucoup
d'investissements à faire sur nos
propres bâtiments j'allais dire et voilà
entretenir le parc
vous parlez tout à l'heure de de route
dégradée ce que ce que vous entendez
finalement ça
bien sûr non pas spécialement j'entends
des promesses ces gens-là ont été ont
été la manoeuvre et on a vu que rien
n'était rien n'y était et j'entendais
les infrastructures et je voudrais faire
une petite parenthèse concernant le pont
le fameux pont de pont puisque forcément
ça devient venir vous imaginez bien mais
on voit aujourd'hui quelque chose
d'incroyable puisque on se rencontre en
regardant un petit peu partout qu'aucun
des professionnels qui utilisent l'Yonne
n'a été consulté voilà donc une fois de
plus j'entends parler depuis tout à
l'heure d'études de réunion mais il
serait peut-être bien en fait de convier
naturellement des élus c'est tout à fait
clair mais de convier aussi quelques
professionnels quelques gens de quelques
hommes femmes de l'art de façon à avoir
des des résultats
on va rapidement sur la question du pont
on va parler ce fameux pont sur l'Yonne
un pont qui a été qui a été donc été
refait dont certains disent maintenant
qu'il est désormais trop bas juste
répondez deux mots pour vous défendre et
après on va passer à monsieur courtois
alors le pont évidemment c'est pas ma
compétence mais il a été fait d'après ce
que j'ai compris selon les
recommandations et effectivement il y a
probablement un rehaussement du pont à
envisager parce que il y a un vrai souci
avec certains professionnels et il y a
effectivement des grosses entreprises
qui ont besoin d'une hauteur de pont qui
soit supérieure à celle qui est
aujourd'hui prévue et qui était dans le
cahier des charges c'est pu répondre il
y a des Cortes
qu'il fallait faire tout de suite
prioritaire
je crois les collèges c'était mentionné
moi ce que je retiens un autre point
supplémentaire dans le nord du
département mais en revanche ne pas
enfermer ça serait déjà pas mal je crois
que malheureusement durant ce mandat
nous avons eu cette épreuve qui nous a
aussi déchiré clairement au sein de la
majorité qui était la fermeture du
collège bienvenue Martin c'est un très
mauvais signal en fait envoyer
à nos jeunes aux parents quand on parle
d'attractivité du territoire fermé un
établissement je trouve que c'est un
très mauvais signal évidemment à la
communauté éducative donc pour moi
l'investissement c'est c'est l'école en
général donc là en l'occurrence le
collège pour les départements donc vous
parlez de la rue du bâtiment c'est ça
bien évidemment bien sûr il y en a un
certain nombre à mettre un jour et à
hauteur de de l'époque c'est à dire que
enfin je veux pas non plus tirer son
ambulance il y a eu le pont c'était déjà
beaucoup pour pour ma collègue mais mais
certains ont établissements qui
aujourd'hui souffrent d'un état de
vétusté qui n'est pas digne d'une
collectivité en 2021 clairement merci on
va refermer donc cette première partie
de l'émission on va parler du RSA jeune
dans quelques instants mais tout de
suite maintenant ce sont les questions
flash
les questions flash donc des questions
simples concrètes dont on vous demande
de répondre en fait en une phrase vous
les avez eu à l'avance on va commencer
tout de suite avec vous Isabelle
offrement Meurice première question à
propos de la limitation de vitesse
maintient à 80 km heure ou retour à 90
sondage de la population
pour ou contre
et avec un seul chiffre en mémoire c'est
qu'on est un million cinq de dépenses
pour remettre à jour tous les panneaux
je vais essayer naturellement oui sur
les portions qui peuvent l'être oui
retour à 90 oui
ce courtois non non par respect à
l'égard de toutes les familles frappées
par les drames de la route et le débat
est toujours le même à chaque fois
qu'une décision est prise en matière de
sécurité routière donc de la pensée non
moi je lancerai aussi une concertation
autour de ce sujet en mettant en avant
aussi le côté très accidentogène des
routes de l'Yonne et des drames qui sont
vécus tous les ans dans notre
département deuxième question le service
public que le département doit soutenir
en priorité monsieur le tiers nous
pensons à nos concitoyens en situation
de handicap mais je pense que la
priorité doit être mise à cet endroit
madame Cola service public il veut
soutenir les compétences prioritaires
donc l'enfance la famille le handicap
les personnes âgées vous aviez demandé
un service public j'irai à l'école donc
dans la droite ligne de ce que j'ai j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure avec les collèges
madame proman Murray
tous il faut qu'on s'accroche et que on
serve le public mais je dirais il y a
une initiative que je souhaiterais qu'on
déploie sur la totalité du département
périmètre par périmètre c'est le bus des
services publics qui vient d'être mis en
service et que je trouve absolument
génial question suivante le département
doit-il participer au financement des
équipements de sécurité des communes
type vidéo surveillance monsieur
courtois non alors je ne crois pas en
revanche ce qui peut rentrer dans le
cadre d'une subvention en titre de
village de l'Yonne c'est une subvention
qui est versée par des départements aux
communes et puis par ailleurs les
communes peuvent également solliciter la
DETR auprès de Monsieur le Préfet sur ce
type de d'équipement
si elle doit être mise c'est dans mon
collège
la vidéo protection c'est une compétence
de l'État et donc elle est financée
aujourd'hui déjà d'ailleurs via la DETR
ième et dernière question faut-il donner
plus d'argent au 10 monsieur courtois
oui clairement il y a eu un large débat
au sein du département de l'Yonne
notamment à l'évocation de la fermeture
du Centre 15 qui a amené l'ensemble des
élus départementaux toutes OBD on se
confondues à se défendre et à manifester
auprès de l'ARS donc la réponse est oui
puisque désormais ce sont bien les
pompiers qui sont en première ligne en
matière de santé c'est la première
mission l'aide à la personne donc oui
les moyens doivent être mis sur le 10
et peut-être particulièrement sur des
équipements de sécurité puisque j'aurais
rappelé que les pompiers aujourd'hui
sont cibles de guet-apens en plus de des
conditions de travail extrêmement
difficiles aujourd'hui on est
proportibles alors que ils viennent
sauver des vies voilà
et l'administratrice du disque que je
suis Lucet des moyens supplémentaires
doivent être mis aujourd'hui la part du
blog départemental et du blog communal à
soulever beaucoup de débats dans les
assemblées du S10 donc oui il faut
absolument que le département continue
d'investir à la fois sur les équipements
mais aussi auprès de ces personnels donc
des pompiers qui sont des fonctionnaires
vous voyez comme quoi tous les courants
se rejoignent sur l'importance du 10 du
service du 15 absolument sur la part du
département qui doit augmenter très
certainement moi j'y suis
personnellement favorable j'ai et donc
je crois que c'est on est tous d'accord
c'est important toute votre majorité
personnellement
on est bien d'accord oui
merci d'avoir joué en tout cas
j'aimerais maintenant qu'on aborde un
autre thème puisque c'est une question
qui se pose en fait actuellement dans
l'ensemble des départements français la
question du RSA jeune j'ai vu madame
Colin que c'était dans votre programme
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce qui vous
amène à vouloir se gérer ça jeune alors
on l'a pas appelé RSA jeune mais plutôt
en direction des jeunes sous certaines
conditions aujourd'hui on a dans ce
département un public de jeunes de
jeunes gens moins de 25 ans qui
rencontre des difficultés qui parfois
ont non plus de relais familiale et qui
ont des difficultés à rentrer en
formation ou en insertion il y a un
dispositif qui fonctionne très bien qui
s'appelle la garantie jeune la garantie
jeune en fait il faut relever les
barèmes et la démultiplier pour
accompagner les jeunes donc et puis il
faut que le département reprenne la main
aujourd'hui la garantie jeune elle est
gérée par l'émission locale qu'il fait
parfaitement bien mais en démultipliant
ce dispositif on va permettre de
travailler main dans la main Mission
Locale département de la même manière
sur sur cette thématique il faut
développer une expérimentation qui a été
faite dans ce département qui est le
service public de l'insertion
le département de l'Yonne a été
territoire d'expérimentation et et je
l'en félicite le Jovinien migenois et le
territoire pour lequel le travail se
fait on voit aujourd'hui des effets
bénéfiques et sur la compagnement des
jeunes ce service public doit se mettre
en place on a encore malheureusement
dans ce département des jeunes qui nous
ont ni emploi ni formations ni cursus de
scolarité et ces jeunes là on doit
effectivement les accompagner ce qu'on
proposera nous c'est un revenu sous
certaines conditions et vraiment
démultiplier cette garantie jeune qui
permet c'est pas revenu en fait on n'est
pas dans un système où on va donner de
l'argent et s'arrêter là on est vraiment
sur un accompagnement renforcé des
jeunes pour leur construire leur
parcours d'insertion
puisque nous préférons épauler les
jeunes qui vont étudier qui vont être
apprentis qui vont aller vers un travail
et c'est vrai que on est sur des
problèmes de mobilité sur les problèmes
peut-être d'accompagnement pour des
rédactions de CV pourquoi pas voilà mais
en réalité de rémunérer
sans garantie que ces forces vives en
fait puissent plus s'exprimer dans les
études dans l'apprentissage dans un
travail et bien non en réalité ce sera
vraiment sous condition
ils avaient raison alors mon avis il est
très simple c'est que le RSA jeune c'est
une trappe au chômage et que justement
nous avons mis en place contre ce
concept contre cette trappe la garantie
jeune c'est pas nous l'apportons
effectivement
parce que justement l'encadrement il est
fait dans le cadre de la garantie jeune
c'est la garantie jeune qui est en fait
un contrat pendant six mois ou pendant
lesquels le jeûne est porté il est
accompagné il est on
le forme et normalement ça débouche sur
un endroit c'est
ça veut dire quoi en fait c'est à dire
que juste donner une indemnité à un
jeune qui n'a pas de formation pas
d'emploi etc c'est quelque chose qui
s'appelle une revenue d'assistance en
fait et ce n'est pas ça qui vais sortir
les jeunes de leurs conditions
difficiles donc une fois qu'il rentre
dans un système d'assistanat ils en
sortent peu on a le même système avec de
en général avec les bénéficiaires du RSA
que malheureusement effectivement on
accompagne pas assez parce que on a pas
assez de moyens je rappelle que
malheureusement le département à 35
millions d'euros de restes à charge
c'est à dire qu'il est payé par les
impôts des iconais pour le RSA dans le
cadre de
je veux juste terminer la garantie jeune
on est à fond pour aujourd'hui
effectivement cette mission elle est
déléguée aux missions locales qui s'en
occupent très bien il y a des
conventions d'objectifs qui sont signés
entre l'émission locale et le Conseil
départemental ça marche très bien et on
a même un système si je peux me
permettre
donc ce sera oui au RSA jeune non RS
voilà ça donne monsieur courtois votre
avis à vous en fait le dispositif
expérimenté dans certains départements
je rappelle que pour bénéficier du RSA
il faut avoir plus de 25 ans sauf que
dans le département de l'Yonne
ces jeunes qui
bénéficient du RSA ou ceux qui
pourraient être en fait des
bénéficiaires en deçà de 25 ans
sont plutôt à des étudiants or c'est pas
nécessairement là le profil de nos
jeunes dans nos départements c'est
peut-être le cas Joigny c'est moins le
cas sur le sur le sud du département et
je rappelle de par ailleurs que certains
jeunes peuvent en bénéficier dans la
mesure où ils ont déjà des enfants donc
ça concerne également beaucoup de notes
jeunesse qui dans nos départements
ruraux ont des enfants très jeunes donc
ce dispositif l'expérimenté je pour
l'instant et pour en avoir discuté
également avec les services et les et
les agents des invités dans nos
départements dans notre département ne
se fait pas forcément ressentir
les jeunes de moins de 25 ans sont tous
étudiants dans ce département il y a
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui
qui sont en grande difficulté parce
qu'en rupture parce qu'en difficulté
pour trouver un sens à leur orientation
alors insertion à leur avenir et qui se
questionne et qui n'ont pas forcément
les moyens pour subvenir à leurs besoins
et la garantie jeune si on la
démultiplie si on apporte justement ce
revenu mais évidemment encadré soutenu
accompagné comme ça doit se faire sur le
volet des bénéficiaires du RSA il peut
apporter quelque chose de positif et
puis aussi et ben on fait des rêves des
jeunes qui vont rester sur notre
territoire et qui vont travailler ici
dans notre département de l'Yonne je
rappelle par ailleurs que le dispositif
est RSA c'est vraiment un retour à
l'activité le département de l'Yonne
malheureusement n'a pas de bon taux de
retour en activité ça c'est aussi une
réalité regardez les choses en face et
c'est lié notamment en fait à
l'accompagnement aujourd'hui l'essentiel
de des bénéficiaires sont accompagnés
par des salariés du département dans les
Ets des travailleurs sociaux or là où on
retrouve les meilleurs taux c'est
souvent
Pôle emploi ou en fait des associations
de retour à l'emploi et des
professionnels qui vont accompagner les
bénéficiaires à un véritable retour à
l'emploi
sur le marché du travail monsieur le
tiers se vous qu'est-ce que vous auriez
à proposer alors si ce n'est pas ce RSA
jeune pour aider en fait les jeunes
adultes qui vont avoir quoi qu'il arrive
des difficultés à trouver un emploi à
insérer dans le marché du travail mais
justement les aider à pouvoir une
formation à pouvoir peut-être reprendre
un petit morceau d'études peut-être
aussi à les épauler pour démarcher les
entreprises peut-être centraliser tout
ça vous parliez tout à l'heure de
d'organismes d'état vous parliez de
diverses organismes mais en réalité on
manque un petit peu d'efficacité mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a une vraie force
vive dans l'Yonne de jeunes qui
demandent qu'à travailler mais en effet
quelquefois je reviens toujours au
territoire un petit peu isolé ruraux ou
un problème de mobilité on n'a pas
obligatoirement quand on est
avec des revenus modestes des moyens
d'acheter un véhicule un véhicule qui
passe au contrôle technique et je vous
ai pas toutes les normes qu'on oblige
maintenant pour pouvoir aller à les
décrocher un job voilà donc je pense que
il va falloir épauler aider être
efficace mais surtout donner envie
redonner envie au lieu de peut-être en
effet subvenir à des besoins ou des
formations
en fait à des jeunes qui recherchent de
l'emploi cette campagne est électorale
nous permet quand même d'être vraiment
très présent sur le terrain moi ce que
j'entends ne la part de la plupart des
employeurs c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
restauration mais pas que vraiment
j'étais ce matin dans un atelier de
mécanique agricole pas de mécanicien
agricoles donc il y a en fait énormément
d'offres d'emploi qui reste sans son
preneur donc ça aussi c'est une réalité
dans ce département alors je voulais
quand même le mentionner je voudrais
rajouter également dernier mot très
rapidement juste qu'il y a un problème
d'éducation effectivement nous avons
énormément d'entreprises chez moi j'ai
quelques entreprises qui cherchent
désespérément des des
salariés c'est pas forcément qui
correspondent et qui ne trouve pas les
candidats qui correspond et qui font
faire des formations spécialement pour
former des soudeurs et autres chez moi
on puisait et dont les salariés
repartent au bout de quelques mois parce
qu'il trouve le travail trop dur etc
c'est une équation très complexe vous
vous arrêtez Isabelle
puisqu'on va arriver en fait ce moment
de vos conclusions et là vous aurez 50
secondes où je pourrais pas vous couper
donc ça va être un réel d'honneur pour
vous donc les conclusions qui vont se
dérouler selon un ordre qui a été tiré
au sort juste avant cette émission on va
débuter avec Frédéric Colas juste avant
que vous commencez on va rappeler que
vous êtes candidate sur le canton de
Joigny et on va voir également les noms
des binômes qui vous affrontent sur ce
canton il y en a quatre autres deux de
droite 1 du rassemblement national et un
divers extrêmement gauche Frédéric col
c'est à vous vous avez 5 secondes 50
secondes merci
cette conclusion j'aurais envie de
vous dire de la gauche dans ce
département elle est historique et que
elle est pour les électeurs du 20 et 27
juin prochain aux élections
départementales l'envie de voir du
changement l'envie d'avoir un
département qui va relever les défis de
demain qui doit apporter une ambition
qui doit aménager durablement son
territoire qui doit construire l'avenir
et c'est le projet avec lionne en commun
que nous portons sur l'ensemble de ce
département mettre les bons
investissements là où il faut construire
une véritable politique d'insertion pour
les plus fragiles protégés et prendre
soin de chacun d'entre nous c'est dans
ce sens que l'ensemble des candidats de
l'Yonne en commun porte cette
candidature les vins et 27 juin 50
secondes
on va passer maintenant à vous Isabelle
froment Meurice je le rappelle vous êtes
donc candidate sur le canton du cœur
depuis ça vous quatre autres binômes 1
de droite
du centre un du rassemblement national
et un de gauche à partir de maintenant
c'est à vous vous avez 50 secondes
la majorité départementale a entamer des
grands projets nous avons assigné la
situation nous avons un bilan qui nous
permet justement d'envisager avec une
très grande sérénité les investissements
dont notre département a besoin tant
dans les collèges que dans les
infrastructures que pour le foyer
départemental de l'enfance que pour les
EHPAD puisque nous avons enfin réussi à
permettre des investissements dans les
prochains dans les prochaines années
dans les EHPAD
nous avons de l'ambition nous souhaitons
nous finirons la fibre en 2023 partout
dans le département et nous nous
réjouissons de pouvoir contribuer encore
une fois au développement de l'Yonne
merci beaucoup on va passer maintenant à
vous que Xavier courtois tout d'abord je
le rappelle vous êtes candidat sur le
canton d'Avalon face à cinq autres
binôme il y a du monde chez vous deux
autres binômes de la droite et du centre
un binôme debout la France un du
rassemblement national et un binôme de
gauche vous avez courtois vous avez 50
secondes c'est à vous oui je crois que
les dernières élections en 2015 avait
montré une forte majorité très bleue
comme vous l'aviez marqué mentionné donc
pourquoi pas en revanche dans ce bleu il
y a du bleu plus clair il m'a paraît
important que cette opinion c'est ce
courant de pensée
moins à droite qu'il n'est aujourd'hui
dans le département de l'Yonne puisse
s'exprimer et avoir vraiment une place
sans aller jusqu'à la gauche vous voyez
il peut y avoir aussi des points de vue
divergents entre le centre droit et le
centre gauche ou la gauche de Frédéric
Colin je crois qu'il est vraiment il
faut deuxième possibilité partement avec
également une nouvelle génération d'élus
au delà de la politique politicienne
c'est également une question de
génération je crois que nous vivons en
2021 et nous avons besoin de d'élus plus
actifs et plus proche de la réalité
d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup on va passer à vous
Jean-Christophe le tiers donc vous êtes
candidat sur le canton de Sarny aurait
depuis hier face à vous trois binômes de
binômes de droite et un binôme de gauche
vous avez 50 secondes c'est à vous
bien le rassemblement national présente
également d'autres binômes puisque tous
les cantons présentent des débiles
rassemblement national mais au-delà de
tout ça on a les mêmes représentants
dans l'Yonne depuis depuis 30 ans et
nous pensons qu'il faut maintenant une
alternance une alternance avec d'autres
élus pour une pour une autre politique
et cette politique que nous proposons il
est en faveur de la réalité de la
ruralité pardon en faveur de
l'environnement mais dans le respect
dans le respect des gens qui vivent ici
qui travaillent ici je pense aux
agriculteurs dans en faveur du
patrimoine puisque le patrimoine est
souvent est souvent l'abandon et là
c'est avec un manque de moyens et puis
un égal accès au service et pour tous
les icônes puisque obligatoirement tout
le monde n'est pas servi de la même
façon on ne l'a évoqué tout à l'heure en
faveur de la sécurité également puisque
la sécurité c'est l'affaire de tous et
puis surtout contre les éoliennes nous
sommes et prononcés merci merci à
mesdames et messieurs d'être venus
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat des
départementales
[Musique]
attraper d'une pandémie qui nécessite
que des gens s'engagent pour lutter
contre et trouve des moyens afin de
pouvoir retrouver des solutions à nos
concitoyens voilà un vrai sujet dans
lequel on a besoin de représenter une
phrase un slogan pour écouter il faut
aller voter simplement pour exprimer son
mécontentement et son envie de retrouver
une un département qui fonctionne une
région qui fonctionne merci à vous
quatre d'être venu débattre sur ce
plateau vous restez avec nous dans un
instant ça terrestre à la Nièvre le
temps d'une annonce très rapide on
revient juste après à tout de suite
[Musique]